si vous voulez plus d'intimidation puis
plus que j'aurais pu chicken dans nos
régions
ben va falloir encore dre la mob
provincial pour falloir la définir mais
en tout cas on se voit pas intimider par
ce que vous nous dites là j'en suis sûr
que si on veut éviter l'intimidation
- madame le commissaire va falloir que
les jambes au fait que le gouvernement
comprenne qu'il prenne ou qu'il est
après comme ils veulent être humain est
immédiatement vous allez devoir
comprendre qu'il va falloir que vous
cessiez de l'intimider je me suis madame
m'excuse madame la présidente je peu
intimidé personnes on va on va avancer
dans nos deux journées on verra bien
mais on n'a pas intimidé personnes quand
j'étais arrivé ça intimide et appuie pas
à peu près puis même avant que j'arrive
représentant g et timide et ce chantier
j'en ai tant de travailleurs qui se
défend de jeter un chômeur pain
bien-être social qu'elle a cherchés
ouvrage puis oui je m'arrête là haut
puis oui j'ai intimité mais quand on est
arrivé où je viens de vous dire madame
la présidente
on a voulu changer les choses c'est
peut-être duraquois être la face que je
et non maman mamie comme un bandit
on a voulu changer les choses on est
encore en train de travailler s'échanger
jose l'habit ne fait pas lemoine ne faut
pas que le monde oublie là on le
travaille là dessus on est encore en
train de travailler là-dessus si ammann
à partir du moment
parce que moi je suis là où je te dis
lol trois ans de travail des
travailleurs de mon local chez nous mais
moi que je suis pas là ils vont se faire
justice lourdement de pareilles
d'intimidation va se faire pareil ils
sont pas respectés chez eux